[Music]
i'm sure you've seen this image before
it's the great wave by hokusai it's
perhaps the most recognizable piece of
japanese art from japan's most famous
artist but around the same time as
making this print hokusai was also
conjuring up strange and frightening
ghosts plucked from japanese folklore
from the story of oiwa a possessed
lantern who haunts her treacherous
husband to the kahadu kaheji a vengeful
corpse that peers over the curtain to
watch you sleep but where did these
monsters come from and why was hokusai
so fixated with ghost stories all this
and more as we step into the ghoulish
art of supernatural japan
our tale begins in japan's edo period
which spanned between the years of 1603
to 1867 a time when the country's rulers
restricted contact with the outside
world with such limited foreign
influence art within japan's borders
flourished particularly a style of wood
block printing called ukiyoe images were
carved onto a piece of wood then covered
in ink and then finally pressed onto
paper revealing the image this method of
printing produced some of the most
amazing artists and artworks but
arguably the master of a kiwi was this
man katsushika hokzai it's believed that
hogwarts created 30 000 unique pieces of
art including his famous hogwarts manga
a 13 volume collection of sketches on
every topic imaginable people animals
plants mythology architecture even
self-defense techniques he also made
some stunning landscapes
can we take a minute to appreciate some
of them
by the age of 70 hokketsai was known
throughout japan but he's yet to have
created his most famous work
his 36 views of mount fuji one of them
included his masterpiece under the great
wave of kanagawa here hawkside depicts a
rogue wave as it plunges down onto the
boats below
this fearsome and dramatic piece was
instantly popular in japan in his
lifetime some five thousand copies were
printed but only a handful of these
originals have survived as he grew into
his old age hakuzai became more and more
interested in the supernatural he spent
much of his time making frightening
prints of ghosts from folklore or as
they're referred to in japan yokai
yokai are weird and mysterious beings
eerie apparitions that inhabit
supernatural japan there's no word in
english that accurately conveys the
meaning of youkai in japanese the term
refers to things that are both strange
and beautiful i can see why they come in
all shapes and sizes from friendly
household spirits to fierce demons let
me introduce you to some of them now up
first there's the oyajirome with its
large bulbous eye on the back of its
head or the domo komo a spirit with two
heads and two personalities what about
the fearsome ushioni one part bull one
part crab and the rest nightmare fuel
but my favorite is the kamakiri this
cheeky bird goblin that goes around
cutting long hair
now around the time that hokusai was
active interest in the supernatural
yokai had boomed trading ghost stories
was a favorite pastime particularly in
the game of hyakumonogatari where
participants would sit in a candlelit
room and take turns telling frightening
tales after each one was shared a candle
would be extinguished until there was no
light left in the room
it was there that the yokai would appear
as an aide to tell these stories
woodblock artists were often
commissioned to provide illustrations
this included hokusei who made a print
series called 100 ghost stories each of
his five images have their own legend to
accompany them and i want to tell you
this one it's the tale of oiwa and it's
one of the most popular ghost stories in
japan
oiwa lived in the city of edo with her
husband iamon yemon was a samurai a
noble warrior of old except that there
was nothing noble about this samurai for
he was secretly having an affair with
their neighbour one day oiwa felt very
sick each day she would get worse and
worse
seeing an opportunity to finally rid
himself of his sickly wife eemon gave
oiwa a potion believing it to be
medicine oiwa drank the concoction
however it was a deadly poison and soon
she was beset by horrific changes her
hair fell out and she was driven mad in
the grips of her illness she fell onto
her husband's sword her spirit passed
into a nearby lantern and she was
condemned to roam the earth as a
vengeful specter day and night she would
haunt emmaud for his betrayal eventually
driving him to madness as well
this super depressing story is captured
in one single image and looking closely
it contains some prompts to help the
storyteller over here we have oiwa's
name and this symbol on our forehead is
the mark of the buddhist god yama the
evil lord of death and the underworld
the other ghost stories are equally as
disturbing with many of them being about
revenge this eerie wood block tells the
story of the servant girl sarashiki
whose spirit emerges out of a well each
night in search of an expensive plate
she once lost hence the snake-like body
made out of crockery
we've also got kahada koiji a former
kabuki actor who was murdered and then
dumped in a swamp in this picture he's
pulling apart the mosquito net having
just found his murderers of course
hoksai wasn't the only artist who
enjoyed painting yokai contemporaries of
hakusai like kunioshi made their own
versions like the story of umibozu a
giant ghostly shadow who appears to
sailors in fierce typhoons but beware
one wrong word and you'll be dragged to
the depths of the sea
these illustrations of yokai showcase
the bizarre imaginations of woodblock
artists similar creatures appear in
european artworks like these headless
humanoids called blemis if you want to
learn more about them consider watching
my field guide to medieval monsters
in the years after hockeytime's death
japan opened its borders to the outside
world hockside's exquisite woodblock
prince reached a wider audience the
great wave in particular today it's one
of the most widely printed artworks of
all time the introduction of western art
led to other changes traditional
japanese manga pioneered by hokusai
morphed with american comic books to
create the manga we know today
even in animation western styles fused
with traditional tastes and practices as
seen in this early experimental cartoon
this evolved into anime and it's through
these mediums we've got to experience
all the wonderful yokai that have come
out of japan a prime example of this is
the animation of studio ghibli in films
like spirited away or pompoco both are
love letters to japanese folklore and
artists like hakusai you might be able
to tell by now but hokusai is one of my
favorite artists and whilst his
woodblock landscapes get most attention
there's something so wonderful about his
ghostly prince there's nothing quite
like them they're so animated and
strange through his spectral yokai
hokusai hints at wonders and horrors
that lurk behind our everyday lives
[Music]
hey thanks for watching i really hope
you enjoyed this one japanese folklore
is certainly something i'm going to
return to so stick around for more if
you like strange and disturbing art then
you'll love my video on the nightmarish
hellscapes of euronymous bosch if you
liked this video and want to see more
why not subscribe a like and a comment
also go a really long way
anyway i look forward to seeing you next
time
goodbye
[Music]
you